vladimir putin's private life or the
wealthy owns are closely guarded secrets
as the war in ukraine continues this has
made it a challenge for the u.s and
western allies to target putin and his
inner circle directly with sanctions but
that hasn't stopped them from trying to
impose them on him and two of his
daughters
president putin and russian oligarchs
stash assets and resources in the bank
accounts and
of their family members and so this was
an effort to get at those assets here's
what we know about the russian
president's family and their assets
unlike western leaders putin doesn't
usually appear in public with his family
members images like this one from state
media showing putin on holiday with his
family in 2002 are rare
in april u.s officials identified
katarina tijanova and maria varanzova as
his daughters
they say one is a tech executive
and the other works in genetics research
both are his daughters from his former
wife ludmila according to the kremlin
putin doesn't discuss them publicly and
they keep such a low profile that many
in russia don't even know what they look
like we also don't know whether putin
has other children or a partner putin
avoids talking about his family for
security reasons according to russia
state news agency tas
and what about putin's assets that
western officials say he's hiding with
family members how much is russia's
president worth and where is his wealth
putin declared a salary of about 130 000
us dollars in 2020
but his critics and political opponents
have long said his wealth is in effect
much greater because of the level of
control and power he has in the country
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you